hey guys Tony coming to you from PAX
East 2017 I just played a little bit of
Final Fantasy 15 episode Gladio now of
course it's plays a little differently
from the main game because Gladio is a
big muscular guy not so nimble like
Noctis but if you want to see more of
this and more Final Fantasy gameplay be
sure to LIKE and subscribe
Gladio yeah who you think it is catch
you at that time
are you here yet yeah I'm at the crow's
nest good thanks for agreeing to meet
with me sure
so are you ready to move out of course
what about you are you mentally prepared
of course we'll be right over
about time
[Music]
will it be just the water's fine thanks
allow me to ask you once more are you
sure you're ready to take on the blame
after I went up against the high
commander and get my ass handed to me I
didn't stand a chance and I never will
unless I get more power then answer my
question are you ready or not you think
I would have called you here if I were
[ __ ]
so you're ready to face death Gilgamesh
awaits challengers in the deepest
recesses of those ruins we've been 30
years since we uncovered the caves
we've sent countless expeditions but all
of our efforts have afforded us no
reward and no survivors except for you
you undertook the trial and you made it
back alive
barely let's move did you tell your
friends why you were taking off just
said it was business didn't want him
getting all worried about me well
knowing your pride took a beating all
right I've got the no turning back now
Wow
your life long
yeah
- not what our souls remain cling to the
vestiges father why those determined to
become the king
the bleep message that explore their
world for and Bianca my hearing off
being women
[Applause]
only way to go down
you come to prove yourself worthy of my
mantle I do I am here to undertake the
trial of Gilgamesh and what is it you
hope to bring power and you're gonna
give it to me
[Applause]
no force well it'll cost you one person
spoke last man equal partner to go
beyond the fighting beside the children
she knows you you thing I don't the
Randy will friends the people of your
world it is but the King of Kings and
his shield who can safeguard their lives
although some word you're unwilling to
rise to the task meet their end here by
my plate I mean mine anytime soon this
trial had made me gun if you do not see
address then go forth with reckless
abandon and prove your worth
you are ready for this in that case but
the trials begin so the blade master you
the master of blades what are you
expecting something profound
come and take a load off
the blade master isn't here to train you
he's here to test you
you won't go easy on you just because
you join the Crown's Guard so no mercy
for newbies like me
so what the week aren't worthy of
serving his shield in his eyes a week on
worthy of living
all of them are fool punished for
aspiring beyond the station I were the
full-back then too and I was punished
when you were killed maybe you weren't
worthy of serving shield but he must
have seen was worthy of living maybe he
did maybe he didn't whenever you're
ready
keep your eyes and ears open done and
done
[Music]
Oh
your skill is impressive you may have
the strength to defeat the darkness but
do you have the spirit to survive these
trial
[Music]
good
coming
mine
you
[Music]
yeah
once this a trial chamber the
hand-holding stops here good luck
prepare yourself young warrior for the
trials that we prove your voice and our
power away
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you